هذا وكانت الدول الحليفه لكيف وعدت بتعزيز
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه في مختلف جولات حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا من ابرز هذه الدفاعات
منظومه نيسانس الامريكيه للدفاع الجوي
يتراوح مدى صواريخها ما بين 15 الى 25 كلم
كما يمكن لمنظومه الدفاع الجوي حارس تي
الالمانيه التصديا للطائره المقاتله
والمروحيات وصواريخ كروز والمسيرات
الانتحاريه تتكون من رادار ومركز قياده
وقاضي صواريخ محموله على شاحنه
القوات الاوكرانيه كذلك استخدمت في صد
الهجوم الروسي صواريخ جافلان الامريكيه
الى جانب صواريخ لاو البريطانيه المضاده
للدروع وصواريخ ستينجر الامريكيه ضد
الطائرات والمروحيات الروسيه
في الجانب الاخر تقريبا استخباراتيا
الامريكيه كشف ان روسيا بصدد شراء اذا
خائره عسكريه من كوريا الشماليه في مؤشرا
على تاثير العقوبات الغربيه على موسكو
كذلك تسلمت روسيا حسب مسؤولين امريكيين
المئات من المسيرات الايرانيه من طرازات
مختلفه
واكدت تقارير غربيه دخول العديد من شركات
السلاح الروسيه في ازمه بسبب ما يمكن وصفه
بالحصار التكنولوجي الذي فرضته واشنطن
ودول غربيه على موسكو اعاقه العقوبات قدره
تلك الشركات على استيراد الرقائق
الالكترونيه
واشباه الموصلات